the Dutch are often hailed as being
progressive particularly when it comes
to soft drugs now Amsterdam is a hot
spot for cannabis tourists with
significant numbers coming here to try
the drug vending coffee shops as a
tourist coming to this city what do you
think this city is famous for the coffee
shops I think for most tourists it's
like well-known things like wheat and
stuff like that wait wait looks like
more than 17 million visit every year
putting a huge strain on the city of
around a million people the situation is
so bad that the mayor of Amsterdam is
actually considering banning tourists
from buying cannabis this briefing from
the mayor highlights the issues it says
65 percent of foreign tourists come to
Amsterdam to use cannabis and visit the
coffee shops and almost half would be
less likely to visit again if Bart if
the mayor bans what sort of impact you
think that will have will they come or
will they not come I think people still
come but not as often or not as many
people know it's one of the main reasons
people do you come people who come will
enjoy their time a little less so maybe
they won't come back everybody is coming
here for the coffee shops if the mayor
is going to stop the coffee shops
tourists will stop coming to Amsterdam
but the survey also showed a more
worrying impact that a ban could have
some 40% of the drug this should be
perhaps a major concern for a city that
is already struggling to deal with the
darker side of the drug industry and
crime a recent report called attention
to the city's problems with hard drugs
violent crime and human trafficking
based on sewage research cocaine
consumption must represent a turnover
value of at least 75 million euros
but there are limitations to that
research subversive crime can take many
forms such as human trafficking and
labor exploitation environmental crime
arms trafficking illegal gambling and
healthcare fraud
it's believed Amsterdam's coffee shops
are aiding and abetting the ugliest side
of the city's drug business now there
are allegations that the coffee shops
themselves deal backdoor with organized
crime gangs and some are being used to
launder criminal money the mayor has
called for a crackdown a clear
separation of markers between hard drugs
and soft drugs has a great urgency
because of the trades and hard drugs
while many cities around the world are
looking to copy this Dutch city's
tolerant model Amsterdam itself may move
away from its long-standing policy
questioning whether the experiment has
only contributed to drug and crime
problems
Charlotte Dubinsky ferati in Amsterdam
you